brothers and sisters helped me on this
new project to sponsor 50 orphans
brothers and sisters inshallah it's 600
pounds a year but i wanted every one of
you guys to get involved by giving even
if it's one pound
please get involved now each other and
help us sponsor 50 offense for an entire
year
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you your progress
with your soul
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
assalamualaikum whatever you better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are willing inshallah
before i start one praise allah the most
merciful the most just or praise his
glory and gratitude belong to him
are we wearing this inshallah in
solidarity uh
with brothers and sisters uh our
palestinian palestinian brothers and
sisters
i'm kurdish in the kurdish culture we
wear this as well problem since
inshallah
and as kurds are ourselves supposed to
we have been we have gone through a lot
of oppression as well
um and subhanallah that's another story
in itself is
but uh we can somehow feel uh what the
palestinian brothers and sisters
uh go through as well subhanallah so i'm
wearing this inshallah uh
to show that now brother sisters there
are two things i want to touch upon and
today is very interesting and bizarre
because i'm going back to this website
which showed
italian dockers stopped stop arm
shipments to israel in solidarity
uh with palestine with palestine yeah
and this was unloading i was trying a
couple of times so i can see
that israel is on their case and
probably sending the hackers to
slow down things monsters which has made
me more determined and encouraged
to do this video further not only that
we had people like zean malik as well so
in our brothers and sisters
from an individual level to a state
level countries level for example like
italy
they are both realizing the oppression
that's going on zayn malik posted i
stand with palestine
with the palestinian people my heart
aches for the families who have lost
loved ones
we cannot stand as silent witnesses
to children being orphaned and murdered
and the fact that he uses these words
from sisters
is very important because that's exactly
what's happening do you know how many
orphans there are in palestine promises
i've done live appeals for certain
charities
it's unbelievable brother sisters yeah
the children they are orphaned
and murdered so apparently and some
people would come to this organization
and say oh you want to sponsor an offer
for a year
you don't even know if that child is
going to live for that long yeah it's
sad
orphaned and murdered and not demand for
the human rights of all palestinians
um this must end free palestine okay
so brother sisters from an individual
level like zayn malik
it's so important for them to do their
job okay
and i'm going to pick on someone called
nas daily yeah
recently he done a video i'm going to do
a specific video for him here i'm so
sorry i'm going to call him a coward
he is a palestinian who identifies as a
palestinian israeli
are you you know israeli you're not
israeli but you're palestinian
are you ashamed of yourself huh
anyway i'm not going to go on a rant
because i've got a separate video
dedicated to him
yeah because people who are silent are
as good as those who are bombing babies
into pieces
israel that's what they're doing and the
international community
and the media after pressure bbc getting
reported to ofcom
and complaints finally are doing
something now
you can see how it really looks like
when the media do that damn job you see
how it
how real things are now going back to
italy yeah and we salute them
they said after discovering that a
shipment of arms destined for israel was
arriving in italy's ports
workers organized in one of the italy's
main unions la union
sindakal the base sorry italia
the other workers organizations refused
to load the ship in support of
palestinians fighting for their lives
against israel occupation
this friday the asiatic asiatic island
arrived in the port of livono italy
thanks to the report of the autonomous
collective of port workers of
genoa and the weapon watch association
the port workers organized in el union
syndical debates
learned that the ship was filled with
weapons and explosives bound for the
israeli docks of ashdod
these weapons and explosives would be
used to kill palestinians who have
already been hit by a brutal israeli
military offense
offensive that has murdered hundreds of
victims including many children
literally blowing babies into pieces
yeah the union announced shortly after
that it would not allow this or any
other
maritime shipments of ornaments or
to set sail uh for israel the dock
workers unions in italy are trying to
gather more information about the
shipments coming to their ports in order
to prevent military
supplies from arrival uh from arriving
in israel
just just yesterday they received a
report about the presence of dozens of
armored military vehicles
ready to be loaded onto another ship the
molo italia
this saturday the same union uh be in
the streets of levano marching in
solidarity with the palestinian
population
to demand the immediate cessation of the
bombing of gaza and evictions
of palestinians from their homes this
example of workers solidarity
of if multi if multiplied and expanded
internationally could be powerful enough
to stop the criminal attacks
of the state of israel against palestine
brothers and sisters
in a nutshell anybody that says
israel has a right to defend itself
anybody
that says there's a conflict happening
here like anyways let's carry on here
you know i'm going to do this video for
him as well yeah
so brothers and sisters in a nutshell
anybody that talks about conflict
that clashes all this kind of nonsense
here in a nutshell
what they're saying is we are with
israel the terrorist state
we are with them and we have no problem
them bombing children
in a nutshell anybody that sees what's
going on and they say we support israel
people have told me robin said this
filthy scum yeah dirtbag
gets funded by israel yeah these people
you can clearly see
that they are in a nutshell they hate
islam
they hate muslims they don't mind seeing
the blood of muslims it's as simple as
that
this is what you need to interpret that
as anybody that comes and says that to
you from now on
i stand uh no um israel has a right to
defend their self
conflict uh clash in the nutshell bronze
sisters what they're just saying is
we're gonna turn a blind eye that's what
we're gonna do so
that's it brown sisters till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh